foreign
hey you guys and welcome back to
flickers of fear going back to the 1970s
for this one all right so the 1979 movie
The driller killer probably as well
known as it is today uh due to the fact
that it was one of the most often
brought up uh movies that was on the
UK's Infamous video nasties list and in
fact
um according to a guy named Mike Bohr
who at the time of this whole brouhaha
was the principal examiner at the bbfc
you know the British Board of film
classification uh this movie which was
directed by Abel Ferreira and is kind of
like a gritty Psycho Drama I guess you
would call it uh his quote was this
movie was almost single-handedly
responsible for the video recordings Act
of 1984. a look up video nasties if you
don't know what I'm talking about
now ironically
um or not you know considering the
Ridiculousness of the reasons that a lot
of films got singled out and put on this
stupid list
um the whole kind of you know conflict
and controversy about the driller killer
I feel like it wasn't so much due to the
content of the movie which was kind of
like graphic in places sure but it was a
lot less violent or gory than a lot of
other movies that were coming out during
the era I kind of feel like um you know
there was some sexuality in there that
maybe people like objected to as well uh
which you know I'll bring up later on
but I kind of feel like the main thing
that sort of put a Target on this
movie's back metaphorically was pretty
much entirely due to its VHS cover so
the movie got a theatrical release in
the United States in 1979 with no issues
at all but when it was later released uh
to Home Video in the UK which I think
wasn't until 1982. uh its distributor
took out like full page ads and trade
magazines
um and they showed like the very very
lurid cover art which is you know famous
nowadays which kind of like showed a
drill bit like going right into like a
screaming dude's head and there's like
blood and everything like that
so um you know all the like Mary White
House and all those little conservative
crybabies were outraged you know citing
the declining morals of the nation blah
blah and uh the driller killer ended up
getting slapped onto the section one the
prosecuted nasties list now from the
title and the marketing of this you
would think that the driller killer was
a straight up slasher film I mean that's
what it looks like that's what it sounds
like but it's actually a lot more
interesting than that what I mean by
that is uh the movie actually does have
a few Hallmarks of slasher movies like a
guy does go around killing homeless
people with a power tool at one point
but honestly it's more of
a kind of I don't even want to say Slice
of Life but it's kind of more of like a
psychological type of horror movie and
kind of like a descent into madness
piece I guess and actually I'd even
argue that it's probably best viewed as
like I said almost like a time capsule
of late 1970s New York like when the
city was just like filthy and rat
infested and just kind of like
constantly haunted by drunks and drug
addicts and the mentally ill who had um
you know shortly before had been kind of
released back into the streets because
of you know budget cuts and whatnot and
it's kind of like there was there was
just this sense that everyone was kind
of Desperately teetering on the edge of
Ruin and kind of spent whatever meager
money they could scrape up on just
Escape in any form that they could find
it whether that was alcohol or whether
it was just drugs or hanging out in
grungy Punk clubs or whatever it was so
driller killer was actually Abel
ferreira's first feature length
non-pornographic movie prior to this
he'd made several short films and a
porno with the delightful title of Nine
Lives of a wet [ __ ]
um which actually sounds like a lot of
fun I'd have to like look that out now
Thriller killer it's definitely low
budget it was made for about 100 Grand I
believe and it kind of shows in places
but I think like a lot of the trademarks
that Abel Ferreira would become known
for during his you know subsequent
career which is very long and kind of
still ongoing
um they're already pretty evident like
even in these early days like there's a
lot of this very pervasive Catholic
imagery and like Catholic themes like
Redemption things like that
um and also his fascination with artists
and their relationship to their art uh
Abel Ferreira actually are um stars in
this one as well like in the lead role
under a pseudonym Jimmy Lane so our
protagonist uh played by Abel Ferreira
is Reno Miller and he's kind of like a
struggling starving art artist guy
living in a kind of like grimy apartment
although it's like not that bad a size
like for a Manhattan apartment now that
I'm looking at I'm like I gotta live
there you know what I mean it is kind of
grimy but it's not that bad
um but it's in Union Square in Manhattan
now he appears and this is kind of what
I was referring to earlier about how
some people might have like objected to
the sexuality portrayed in this he
appears to be in some kind of like
polyamorous Triad they never call it
that it's not really defined but
nowadays if you saw it that's probably
what you would call it so it's him and
it's his girlfriend Carol who's played
by Carol Mars who looks eerily like a
Proto Catherine Zeta Jones I was like is
that Catherine Jada Jazz she looks a lot
like her
um so she's actually recently divorced
her husband and is kind of like you know
spreading her wings and trying to be
free and doing whatever and also Carol's
girlfriend Pamela who's played by baby
day she's kind of like a Spacey like
Punk Rocky kind of like party girl so
the three of them are living in this
apartment and they're living like a lot
of people did in New York back then like
very very much hand to mouth like Reno
does seem to have sold some of his art
in the past like judging at least from
his interactions with Dalton Briggs
who's the art dealer that he Associates
with and Carol actually gets an alimony
check from her ex-husband uh it's not
real clear how Pamela makes any money if
she does but the trio are a couple
months behind on their rent and they
also just received this like big huge
phone bill that they can't afford to pay
uh mostly because Carol and Pam have
been making like a bunch of long
distance calls now the piece that Reno
is currently working on though uh is
supposedly it's gonna change everything
for them or at least kind of that's what
he's convinced himself and he's
convinced them of it too so it's a
painting and it's like a big huge
depiction of what looks like kind of
like a frightened Buffalo and it's
overlaid with these sort of like ragged
red claw marks it's kind of a cool
painting actually
um and even though like from our point
of view it looks finished um Reno being
like an artiste and whatnot he kind of
like refuses to take it to the dealer or
refuses to have the dealer come see it
until he's completely satisfied with it
even though you know they're all like
hurting for money right now and it would
like be really helpful if he could sell
it
um right now actually though even goes
to Dalton's office and asks for an
advance on the painting even though the
dealer hasn't even seen it yet
um but Dalton says no because he says
he's already given Reno like several
advances one of which was for his
girlfriend's abortion so he's like yeah
not giving you any more money bud so you
know obviously all of these Financial
stresses are really kind of taking a
toll on everyone
um you know they're often stuck in the
apartment watching TV because they can't
afford to go out and do anything now one
evening in kind of like a little
significant thing that happens uh Reno
sees this commercial on TV for something
that's called a Porto pack
um and it's kind of like this belt like
battery pack for using power tools on
the go like before you know now nowadays
it's like you know it's just like a
battery blah blah but back then you had
to have this big belt with batteries on
it uh and he kind of becomes like
entranced with that he's like oh you can
use power tools like while you're
walking around that's really neat and
there's another kind of significant
thing that happens is he's kind of Up on
the Roof like watching the streets or
whatever and he's kind of simultaneously
horrified but also sort of fascinated by
this incident that he Witnesses in the
street one day where a dude like across
the street from his building is just
randomly stabbed and like left for dead
in the middle of a busy sidewalk like in
broad daylight so as if the pressure of
being broke and kind of just living on
the margins of society and living kind
of in this shitty neighborhood wasn't
enough
Reno's um artistic concentration is
disrupted when a no Wave band called The
Roosters who are actually friends of
pamelas and she's the one that
recommends them for this building they
move into the building and I don't know
if it's upstairs from their apartment or
downstairs I'm not really sure
um so they move in and they basically
start rehearsing like day and night they
must be like totally coked up because
they're saying like they just never stop
they're constantly constantly playing
over and over and over and there's a lot
of footage of them rehearsing in their
apartment so you know but I'll get a
little bit more into that later so Reno
starts getting increasingly agitated by
this constant noise like you can't
concentrate on his painting and you know
subsequently his relationship with Carol
begins to deteriorate and he starts like
snapping at her and saying all kind of
horrible things which apparently he
didn't do before so he goes to complete
into the landlord about the band but the
landlord is like meh not my problem it
says the music doesn't bother me and you
don't really have any right to [ __ ]
because you are a couple months behind
on your rent anyway so you're
essentially like living here for free
um but then like in a gesture of
Goodwill he says okay well I'll say
something to them I'll say that somebody
called the police or somebody won't say
it's you and then also somewhat randomly
um he offers Reno a skinned rabbit to
eat like he had had a rabbit in his
office before that you assumed was a pet
but I guess he killed it and skinned it
like for food and I think the fact of
him giving them the rabbit I could be
totally wrong about this but I don't
think I am I think it was perhaps a nod
to repulsion the Roman Polanski movie in
1965 because that also had to do with a
person like isolated an apartment who's
like going batshit crazy and kind of
becomes fixated on a skinned rabbit that
she's gonna eat for dinner so I'm pretty
sure that that wasn't a coincidence I
think that's a deliberate so later on
Reno starts cutting up the rabbit to
cook and he just ends up kind of
flipping out and mutilating it instead
and like a pretty gross scene actually
because I think that actually is a real
like rabbit carcass and I should note
too that at around this time there are
like definite hints now that he's
probably well not probably he's
definitely like losing his mind like he
keeps having nightmares and like flashes
of himself like covered in blood and he
starts hearing Carol's voice when she
isn't there and he starts to see kind of
freaky [ __ ] like he sees Carol with her
eyes plucked out and like somebody in a
big bunny head like ducking into the
bedroom like just weird [ __ ] like that
and he's also kind of started to fixate
on the homeless people that are always
kind of like hovering around the
building like at first he was just going
out and sketching them and it's implied
that he had that he did that a lot
because they kind of like knew who he
was you know what I mean but as the
movie goes on he kind of starts you know
getting like acting more like aggravated
toward that them and like ranting at
them you know about one thing in another
now because of a scene at the very very
beginning of the movie
um where Reno actually gets summoned to
a church in his neighborhood because
this transient man was brought in who
had a piece of paper that had Reno's
name and phone number on it and Reno
goes to see who it is because they're
like well we thought maybe like he was a
relative or something and he goes over
there and the dude touches him and he's
like repulsed and like freaks out and
everything so we're kind of LED this
isn't stated explicitly but we're led to
believe that Reno has like almost like
an intense fear like shading over into
hatred of like homeless people
um perhaps because the man in the church
was actually his father although he
denied it and also because Reno is
probably terrified that he could very
easily end up just like him or just like
one of the other you know Drifters and
transients and homeless people that are
kind of like you know hanging around in
his neighborhood so finally this kind of
swirl of anxiety comes to a head and
Reno grabs his drill and his trusty
Proto pack and starts prowling the
streets of Manhattan pretty much like
murdering homeless men willy-nilly and
just like big bloody Fountains of
Carnage you know what I mean uh like way
more blood than end than one person has
in there but you know I'll get into that
in a second too now his crimes are
actually like reported in the papers
because obviously like go somebody go
around killing homeless men with a drill
I mean that's newsworthy sure but uh
nobody really suspects that he's the one
responsible so after he's actually
killed several people like in horrible
ways he actually declares that his
painting is now finished and he asked
Dalton the art dealer to come have a
look at it and like make an offer so
Dalton comes over and he completely
eviscerates it he's just like this is
completely worthless like what the [ __ ]
are you even doing like you got me over
here if this is a waste of my time I'm
not buying it and basically just like
storms out of the apartment
now because Reno just kind of sits there
blankly as basically all him and his you
know two girlfriends dreams of riches
just go up in smoke uh Carol has you
know one girlfriend like just blows her
stack like first she starts screaming
after Dalton like as he's leaving but
then she kind of like focuses a lot of
her rage on Reno for basically just like
sitting there like a douche and not like
standing up for himself
um and she's fed up so she finally
leaves and ends up going back to her
ex-husband and that appears to be kind
of like the final nail in the coffin of
Reno's sanity now Reno actually does end
up killing Dalton like for dissing his
Buffalo painting but it's actually the
movie actually leaves unclear whether he
killed Pamela or Carol
um which I found kind of an interesting
decision I mean I feel like it does kind
of follow more in line with Reno's
pathology like is laid out in the film
because it wasn't so much the women in
his life that he was angry at uh but the
men in his life that he was angry at
like I said it's kind of like almost
misplaced rage like toward his father
um you know particularly the old bums in
the street who were kind of like an
ever-present reminder like I said not
only of his own father who it's implied
was also a transient like that but of
it's like you know you don't sell a
painting like you're gonna end up just
like that because you're not gonna have
any money and that was like his worst
fear apparently so as I mentioned like
the driller killer it's not exactly a
slasher film so don't go into it
expecting that yes I know like the title
sounds like a slasher film and yes I
know the cover looks like a slasher film
and it does have slasher film kind of
aspects to it toward the end but don't
if you go into it just expecting a
traditional slasher film you're gonna
have a bad time because it's not like
that Abel Ferreira in fact has often
referred to as a black comedy which I
guess it sort of is and that's kind of
like going back to what I said earlier
about when he goes around and starts
drilling all the homeless men
um you know they have like way more
blood than I mean they're the the murder
scenes aren't fun money but they're kind
of like over the top in a very very
subtle kind of way which is like with
all these Fountains of blood and stuff
and I think that that's what he means
kind of when he says that it's kind of
like a black comedy I kind of get what
he's saying but if it is a black comedy
it's a very Grim very downbeat uh black
comedy for sure uh this movie is like
really grubby it has some amateurish
aspects although not as many as you
might think like um you know given the
budget and the time that it was made
actually a lot of the acting is quite
good and a lot of the scenes as far as I
could determine were improvised uh you
know what I mean that they didn't have
like they had a script and like [ __ ]
like that but basically they just said
well this is the situation like make
something up so there is like a pro
improvisational tone to it which
actually like lends to a little bit of
the naturalism to it but yeah there is a
real solid story in here and kind of I
guess like a slightly deeper thematic
resonance than your usual like cheapy
exploitation flick that came out around
this period because like I think this
gets lumped in with those kind of movies
and it's not really like that there's
definitely like something more going on
in this one now I do admit that the
movie gets a bit rambling in places like
it tends to meander uh you do get the
sense that Abel Ferreira like just shot
a a bunch of footage of like his friends
and like actors just improvising things
or just acting like their usual selves
um so I'm gonna say if you don't have
much patience for like hanging around in
scuzzy apartments and even scuzzy or
Punk clubs with a bunch of kind of like
late 70s no wave New York City druggies
artists musicians like that kind of
thing then you might find yourself like
kind of bored or like kind of annoyed
and wondering hey when the hell is all
the drilling gonna happen now I actually
always really was into this era and this
whole art and music scene like I'm
really into like a lot of no wave stuff
especially like swans and you know Lydia
lunch and stuff like that and this is
kind of like that sort of thing like
when New York was like a [ __ ] and
there was just all this kind of you know
it just like Punk and avant-garde like
art and stuff like that going on so I
actually didn't mind all the time that
was spent like essentially like
immersing the audience into the world of
these characters because this is you
know a scene that I find really
interesting and I'd argue as well that
kind of just watching these people go
about their lives in you know these kind
of shitty what was then like the Mean
Streets of New York City when everyone
was poor it really kind of like amply
conveyed just the poverty and the filth
and the dirtiness and the hopelessness
that was kind of like endemic to the
period like more than any dialogue or
anything more out you know kind of more
um outright would have done so I mean
it's a really dirty depressing movie for
sure and one like I said that maybe
meanders around too much for its own
good and does leave some plot threads
unexplored like especially like what
happened to Pamela I was kind of
wondering about that but I always found
it pretty compelling like despite all
that um you know though of course your
mileage may vary I have seen like some
horror fans that really don't care for
it they just think it's too boring or
like it takes too long for [ __ ] to
happen but you know and I can see that
like that's a valid criticism but I
don't know I just find all the
characters interesting I find the time
period interesting so but I think that
um your enjoyment of the film is really
going to hinge on that I kind of
recommend it just not across the board
but I'd recommend it to anybody that
digs that kind of like CD 70s 80s New
York City Vibe that you see in movies
like maybe Maniac or chud or Basket Case
or hell like even taxi driver or
something like that if you're into that
kind of like scuzzy New York City movies
then you'll probably get really into it
other than that probably not and like I
said don't go into it expecting a
slasher because it's not really so
that'll do it for this flickers of fear
hope you enjoyed it and I will see you
guys again on the next one bye